c'est un peu tout le paradoxe de la
situation c'est que les forces armées
ukrainiennes ne revendiquent jamais les
attaques répétées sur cette péninsule
depuis qui est frappé depuis plusieurs
jours et pourtant on le sait leur
enseignement britannique et également
américains l'affirme se sont bel et bien
les Ukrainiens qui frappent cette
péninsule annexée en 2014 mais ils ne
veulent pas dire ou comment pourquoi ils
essayent de d'entretenir cette sorte
d'ambiguïté pour maintenir une pression
sur cette péninsule qui n'a pas été
épargné ces derniers jours a été elle a
été frappé au nord au centre également à
l'est le président voulait me dire
zenzky qui est encore une fois dans son
allocution n'a pas été
n'a pas caché que que la Crimée est très
très importante pour l'Ukraine en ce
moment il l'a dit je le cite il y a
littéralement un sentiment qui flotte
dans l'air Crimé que l'occupation est
temporaire et que l'Ukraine revient
sous-entendu nous frappons nous
maintenons la pression sur cette
péninsule ils ne disent pas évidemment
avec la Crimée en 2014 elle se terminera
avec la cumée avec la Crimée lorsqu'elle
sera libérée car il l'a répété la Crimée
est ukrainienne n'est pas russe